so percentage peeking a bigger
percentage say 72% something with that
$0.72 okay yes remember what I said
actually means it's an abbreviation I
don't hug it exactly right
72 percent sit just like century right
says 100 years of Tetra okay so
therefore 72 percent is really 72
divided by a hundred okay now you can't
get your calculator out of course to do
this but if you remember especially we
look at scientific notation under number
skills right we did a lot of work
multiply by tens or hundreds of
thousands also dividing okay so if I
divide by hundred I can just think about
movie moving a decimal place right so if
I slap my decimal place on there okay a
dividing so which way does the decimal
point go if it went through the right
for example some hundred twenty it would
make the number bigger I don't want to
make it bigger so left is correct okay
so I'm going to the left because of
division I might drop that thun and how
many places am I going are going to
places okay because there are two zeros
okay so that's harder to get the right
number so that's just going to be 0.72
you can see the decimal places just in
front of the seven okay do be careful
where you've got things like 6% right
it's not just zero point whatever the
number is okay if I reverse this again
if I go six point zero divided by 100 if
I move the decimal place twice right
yeah so it moves once before the six but
then it moves again so I have to add a
zero room so six percent is 0.06 just
for interest if I had written down a
zero point six what would that be equal
to as a percentage it's not six percent
yeah
yeah it's right we know great why to you
none of you okay but you can see and I
could rewrite this I suppose a 0.60 are
you can see the 60 now got you okay but
usually we don't write that with a
decimal